[Music]
hopefully we've shown some light on the
ninth circuit I know that Chief Justice
Roberts John Roberts has been speaking a
little bit about it and I think we've
and I have a lot of respect for them I
like them and I respect them but I think
we have to use some common sense this
nice ninth circuit everybody knows it
it's totally out of control and what
they're doing what they're saying the
opinions are very unfair to law
enforcement they can't believe the
decisions that are being made by these
judges president Trump expressing his
frustration with parts of the federal
judiciary on this Thanksgiving Day as he
looks at the immigration laws a pet
project of his also the president
hinting at the possibility that the
commander in chief could go visit the
troops sometime soon
very much for doing the job and I'll see
you back when you're in the United
States or maybe I'll even see you over
there you never know what's going to
happen I know what you have to do and
I've seen it in a lot of different forms
but I've seen the waters that you have
to go through and very few people can do
it takes special people to do it
commander chief calling the troops and
visiting with some Coast Guard folks in
person let's bring in our panel Michael
Warren senior writer at the Weekly
Standard Alex Wayne White House editor
for Bloomberg News and Tom Rogan
commentary writer for the Washington
Examiner Tom your thoughts on the
commander in chief he's not been to a
war zone yet what do you think is he
going soon I think he is going soon I
think we will see that certainly before
Christmas but potentially even in the
next couple of weeks I think Afghanistan
will be the natural place that he will
go and one of the interesting things
with the president is that you do see
and we've obviously seen with the Chief
Justice Roberts the tension about the
separation of powers the notion of
constitutional powers the president
earlier today as well was speaking to a
naval officer who was talking about
nuclear physics oddly and it was very
striking to see and this is where I
think you see president Trump having a
pretty good rapport with the military
brass the elites the four-star generals
as well as the enlisted personnel that
he has he does have a deference to their
expertise I think he likes the fact that
their job is to close with and destroy
the enemy
personally but but at the same time I
think it is to the president's credit we
he's at his best in a way with the
military in the sense that he defers to
better judgment but he also has a
respect for it and he is willing to to
listen and in that earlier discussion
with the nuclear physics guy or the
officer today you know he there was a
disagreement but he was like well okay
you said I sort of agree with you you
don't see that with other people so I
think the opportunity for the White
House coming off the back of the
midterms to go to a war zone is to say
actually the president as george w bush
was to a degree in the compass zone outs
we remember george w bush going to war
zones on the holidays president obama
made several visits your thoughts on
this president as our White House editor
on the panel
well it's puzzling he hasn't gone
already by by this point in his
presidency Barack Obama had gone to Iraq
once he'd gone to Afghanistan once and
in just a couple of weeks on December
3rd of 2010 Barack Obama went to
Afghanistan for a second time so it's
not clear really why Trump hasn't gone
yet Jim mattis has said he's advising
not to go to certain places didn't name
any of those places but it suggests that
perhaps things are maybe worse than
Afghanistan than the public is really
understands at this point that it's just
not safe enough for the president to
visit this gets to a sort of a
complication with any trip for the
president to a combat zone in the Middle
East which is that the President himself
has stated his opposition to the United
States military being involved in
Afghanistan he sort of was pulled
kicking and screaming by his advisors to
continue into a our engagement in
Afghanistan and I think he's very
frustrated with the way that has gone
since he agreed to that southern a South
Asia policy as he did last year the same
in Syria fighting Isis I think he wants
to be done and out of there so what a
trip to visit the troops there send a
mixed message is it's a would it maybe
be perceived as an endorsement I think
those are the kind of things that this
very sort of public relations conscious
president is thinking about it's
interesting to hear him tease that but
I'm skeptical that he's going to follow
through what do you gentlemen make
the back-and-forth between the president
and the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court Michael let's start with you I
think it's he's certainly not the first
president to grumble about a court
ruling going against him and against its
administration I think what's different
here is the public way that he's going
about it in the personal way he seems to
be taking this that this is you know he
talks about oh this judge was appointed
by a Democrat I was appointed by Obama I
think that's where you're getting
Justice Roberts really kind of feeling
like he has to defend the impartiality
or rather the independence of the
judiciary that look we may be nominated
by presidents of a certain party but at
least ideally we are we are that
president's guy on the bench for the
rest and you do hear this you know
Gorsuch you know the president's first
major accomplishment getting a mountain
Supreme Court very early on in his
Supreme Court tenure ruled against the
president on an immigration issue so you
often see this where these judges rule
against them the president seems to take
it too personally your thoughts yeah you
know I think it's this president has
upset so many norms and expectations
that weight that we had for the
presidency before he took office and one
of those in challenging institutions
that his predecessors would never have
so publicly challenged that the courts
are one of them the Federal Reserve is
another example he's repeatedly
criticized the Federal Reserve and and
the chairman of the Fed personally for
raising interest rates you just didn't
hear that from previous presidents and
it's taken some getting used to I think
there are some consequences to it I
think I think he risks shaking
confidence in those institutions by
criticizing them Tom your thoughts you
know clearly I think analytically you
look at the traditional role of the
judiciary in terms of the constitutional
binding separate-but-equal
Chief Justice Roberts had to stand up
for the court we all know that there are
political ideologies that behind
different judges but at the principle
there must be equal justice under the
law chief justice stand up there but
again I was quite striking today
President Trump very presidential in a
in an unusual sense for the president in
the sense quite normal in the sense that
he was you know having this sort of
disagreement politely with the naval
officer but he also said Chief Justice
Roberts I respect the guy you know there
was no animosity that
you normally see and sometimes I think
with Trump it's almost like he's out on
the yacht tweeting and then it comes
back into that moment and he thinks
about it as long as someone has the
respect you're the president right
doesn't make it personal if you do that
with the president look he listens more
okay so in our brief time left in this
segment I want to briefly get to half
Judiciary Republicans calling former
Retta lynch Attorney General and James
called me up to the hill briefly I think
very briefly what they should have done
and what probably will happen ultimately
is you have an open and a closed session
there is some classified stuff there
some of it very classified because of
foreign allies but but do both ways and
it Comey has a point though that there
is some political agenda here just do
both open and closed as a journalist I'm
a big fan of Jim coming to having a
public hearing instead of a closed-door
interview if there's Republicans and if
it's closed there will be leaks from the
Republicans and there were leaks from
the Democrats nobody will agree on what
was actually said I think that's a
problem getting clarity of what they're
looking for is it too late should they
have done this before the midterms yes I
think so and look I think I think Jim
Jim Comey doesn't do himself any favors
by sort of getting out ahead of his
lawyers statement making this this tweet
here I think it altima Lee makes him
look a little petty and the lawyer
statement should speak for itself